c'est encore un risque et ce n'est qu'un
gâteau au fromage mais pour seul enjeu
thébaux faire un simple dessert est
devenu tout un projet j'achète le
fromage je pressens malheur va la télé
peut pas tout acheter un paquet c'est
trop cher
c'est d'ailleurs pour mieux affronter la
hausse des prix des aliments et du
carburant qu'elle est près de 75 mille
néo brunswickois à faible revenu
recevront un chèque du gouvernement
provincial
225 $ par personne ou 450 $ par famille
coût total de l'opération 20 millions de
dollars 225 dès lors qu'est ce que ça va
changer pour vous
pas grand chose pas grand chose chaque
mois je peux acheter
une est probablement insuffisante admet
le premier ministre mais le maximum que
son gouvernement pouvait offrir sans
hausser les impôts souligne-t-il non ce
n'est pas suffisant pas du tout c'est
juste une fois seulement vrai pour
l'opposition les troupes de bmx doivent
en faire plus on connaît plein de gens
qui font en moyenne une cinquantaine de
milles dollars par année
et non pas d'elle aujourd'hui avec cette
annonce
c'est en fait moins de 10% de la
population qui est visé par la mesure
une approche différente de celle du
québec où tous les travailleurs qui
gagnent moins de 100000 $ par année ont
droit à une aide financière s'il faut
être prudent si rené des mesures plus
universel qui couvre un plus grand
nombre de gens en leur transférant d
argent et que ça va augmenter la
consommation ça risque d'augmenter les
pressions inflationnistes
des pressions que s'allonge restons au
quotidien et qui n'ont pour elle rien de
rassurant mais si je faisais le mort moi
voir ce qui va arriver je me couche le
soir et je pense
ici mathieu papillon radio-canada
saint-louis-de-kent